this season on Darcy and Stacey whoa
it was like a wave it's beautiful
it looks like astronaut suit go baby yes
baby yes I'm ready to open my heart
again
having two really bad breakups has not
been easy for me I'm ready for a new
chapter
[Music]
he's my rock we're meant to be together
[Music]
this is very such a meet
[Music]
maybe gotta 480 oh I feel like I'm
falling in love again so big good strong
I can't help it he's a hot sexy
Bulgarian guy who's all the Jean City
honey it's almost too good to be true
salute to trusting each other I'm
worried that Florence in a break
Stacey's heart he's in a picture with
this woman with are they any clothes on
- no don't tell me - right
I want to know the story I want to plan
my wedding and and be in a happy
relationship she has pictures that look
pretty compromising what are you gonna
do about it if I don't marry Florine I
can't fathom that whatever happens in
the end it will be a strong powerful
woman it's your boy Suzy it's over
as who olds have to worry about other
[ __ ]
I don't want to talk about any more with
bus I'm tired from this I'd give you
some reasons don't trust me if you love
me show me I just feel like I don't know
enough about him so is that your baby do
you have a baby I want to build a life I
want a future sick of it
you
[Music]